no rush here for la leonard 7-2
hawaii makes his move oh wow
[Applause]
that's three points made up off of a
call that should have been made
amen oh james amen on that but spinning
on the slam
playing well great left to right spin by
james
and his sprint down the court was even
better
a mouth a gate impressed with himself
[Music]
connecting catching through three
halfway down and out
antenna oh flex on
bodies are strewn all across the lane
there's a mushroom cloud
underneath with all the physical play
going on doris
after he missed those first two got his
rhythm
by getting to the rim and then have the
presence
to finish up over the top on bogey
rj barrett just eviscerated the wreck
and we are tied in new york
simmons comes out of the pack here is
embiid now
oh my goodness
the little look away a little euro and a
little big board jam right there for
embiid
one point game
[Music]
each one more pushes jay crowder throws
it up for eight
i thought it was going out of bounds
crowder
and the human pogo stick over the top of
zubat
for the three-point play opportunity
it hasn't been a real reliable second
option
here comes
after finishing with the fifth best
record in the nba and a ton of injuries
during the regular season
leonard gets the steal three on one
[Applause]
him in the basket in the backdrop
thought he was fouled on the play here
comes young
looking for his first basket of the
quarter lobs
oh collins with one hand on top of him
[Applause]
wow this is just a great pass but a
terrific athletic move
any time that you can devote over a
seven foot guy at 280 pounds
this is a great jumping
no rush here for la leonard seven to
shoot kawhi makes his move
oh wow a major kawhi lights
incredible on both ends of the ball
and why leonard emphatic
with that finish the nba playoffs on tnt
western
crowded
[Applause]
it's over
what a perfectly executed play
[Music]
what an incredible job by monty williams
designing that play to perfection
but there's time on the clock
deandre who was terrific tonight 24
points 14 rebounds
with the biggest shot of his life